wo war denn die groko in den letzten
tagen von frau merkel gab es zu chemnitz
alles zusammengerechnet vielleicht drei
sätze von den anderen groko leser ganz
zu schweigen
aus dem kabinett war einzig
familienministerin giffey in chemnitz
ihr ministerium finanziert programme
gegen extremismus und sie war ohnehin
auf reisen in der gegend wie praktisch
gut aber deutlich besser als heiko maas
wer uns bürger im interview ermahnt mal
zitat vom sofa hochzukommen ja da werden
wir noch ungefragt belehrt wie wärs denn
mal mit kroko politik die das leben der
menschen konkret besser macht überrascht
uns doch mal nimmt richtig kohle in die
hand damit wohnraum in großstädten
wieder bezahlbar wird oder was weiß ich
versemmelt weniger abschiebungen keine
ahnung und wo wir gerade dabei sind was
macht eigentlich unser innenminister ich
bin eigentlich nur dann wenn ich nichts
gesagt haben horst die migration ist die
mutter aller probleme seehofer für mich
offiziell der großvater der geistigen
inkontinent
getoppt meine damen und herren getoppt
wird das alles wirklich nur noch von der
afd
die in chemnitz ganz offen mit pegah und
neonazis marschiert ist das kann man gar
nicht mehr bestreiten großes thema diese
woche soll der verfassungsschutz die afg
als gesamtpartei beobachten also um
herauszufinden ob den ich doch auf dem
weg sind rechtsextrem zu werden ich bin
dagegen seien china ich bin dagegen
warum steuer geld verplempern für das
offensichtliche ja
spart euch die mühe herzlich willkommen
zu das wasserdichte heute-show
verfassungsschutz beobachten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt dabei sein
ja
lieber verfassungsschutz mein vorschlag
zieht euch einfach irgend ein
prominentes afg zitat ich sage es ist
immer zum kotzen
los gehts wir haben wir einen gewissen
bernd hocke er meint zum thema holocaust
wir brauchen nichts anderes als eine
erinnerungs politische wende um 180 grad
oder was haben wir hier allahs steinke
von der jungen alternative niedersachsen
stauffenberg war ein verräter ich dachte
das kann man so sehen wenn man nazi ist
zu gehen haben wir hier und das ist auch
sehr sehr schön das ist die afg
hochtaunuskreis sie hat gepostet bei uns
bekannten revolution wurden irgendwann
die funkhäuser sowie die presseverlage
gestürmt und die mitarbeiter auf die
straße gezerrt
darüber sollten die medienvertreter
hierzulande einmal nachdenken denn wenn
die stimmung endgültig gibt dann ist es
zu spät jetzt habe ich angst meine damen
und herren so kommen letzten immer noch
war der mann war damals sehr gut peter
böhringer mitglied des bundestags für
die afg er sagt die merkel nutzen lässt
eben rein
sie schafft das ich würde sagen
[Applaus]